good morning everyone and welcome to the
Tuesday February 6th edition of the the
science technology and energy committee
as is our custom we'll start today by
asking all to rise and joining
representative de Bernardi as he leads
us in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all
okay so stn is closing in on the end of
its house activity
for
2024 today we're going to have a full
committee work session this morning on
six
bills and at 1:00 this afternoon we're
going to have an executive session on
those same six
bills four of the bills that we will be
discussing in our work session this
morning have amendments proposed
amendments and two of them have no
proposed
amendment so we'll Begin by discussing
the first
bill and I mention the proposed
amendments but I don't see copies of the
Amendments so we'll have to uh we'll
that so we will uh arrange to get copies
of the all the Amendments shortly I did
send out amendments to the first bill
we'll be discussing which is House Bill
FN the original title of which was to
suspend New Hampshire's participation in
emissions reduction credit programs for
a period of two years and we do have an
bill and we will have it it shortly but
everybody has received a copy in their
email so everybody should be aware of
it essentially what the amendment does
is
it asks the relevant state agencies
to look at Timber taxes and determine if
there's a way to help cities and towns
that rely on Timber tax recover a lost
Timber tax revenue
that's the first section of the bill the
second section of the bill sets up a
registry of land Parcels that
participate in carbon capture credit
programs and uh so it's a relatively
simple bill but it does two very
important things and uh so I would
entertain any discussion from members of
the committee about this proposed
amendment representative Thomas thank
you um Mr chair um just to clarify so
there's no moratorium um in this we're
this discussion we're we're eliminating
any kind of a two-year moratorium or
anything like that correct that is
correct thank you just clarifying
further discussion representative muns
thank you Mr chair um I um I like the
amendment um there were there were three
issues that I heard during the testimony
one was a concern about loss tax
revenues um um the timber tax so this
this addresses that the other two were
um disruption to the timber industry and
um um recreational access to lands and
um I don't think we can address either
of those other two until we know the
universe uh that we're talking about and
and I think the registry addresses that
so um uh and then also um any any
discussion or consideration of any kind
of a tax on carbon credits that the
state may want to impose to recover
Revenue you need to you need to know um
again what land you're talking about so
I I think the amendment does a nice job
forward thank you press the wrong button
rep Vice chair Thomas uh thank you Mr
chair um yes I like this amendment too I
do have a question just for
clarification because we talked about
other methods in establishing a registry
uh is the division of farsy do they all
do they already have a registry and this
is just a simple um addition to it or
how do they intend to U establish and
maintain a
registry this is the state agency that
takes takes care of Timber taxes they
have a Timber tax form so they are
already versed in the business of
creating forms
and tracking data related to Timberland
owners so so we don't need to to go to
the grer of Deeds then we do not okay
good any further discussion
representative reels yes thank you Mr
chairman um yeah like others I
appreciate um very much like the
amendment I think the original bill was
kind
of you know it was naming a problem but
it was proposing a solution that wasn't
actually uh within the power of the
state to do
um and so this bill does two things that
will move the
state and the
municipalities uh concerned you know
closer
to it'll it'll perhaps enable a
solution uh to the ultimate problem
of you know L Timber tax revenue uh to
the municipalities to
emerge um yeah so thank you I like it
representative
Harrington um first a question I guess a
statement uh I'm really uh concerned
about this underlying um Bill RSA 7795 I
believe uh I don't think it's apparently
it's never been implemented which is a
good thing but telling people they have
to pay additional taxes for not cutting
wood on their own land I find very
troubling in fact I think that law would
probably be thrown out by the courts
because it's vague and there is no
requirement for size of the of the lot
or it's so subject to uh interpretation
as with who thinks when's it's mature
and when it isn't that's that's the
underlying problem that with the bill
itself I'm a little uh confused it says
including requirements for owners of
such land to file notice of enrollment
so if someone has land and they decide
to enroll in one of these carbon capture
ones then they will have an obligation
to uh contact the estate and and list
the the land in this registry how are
they going to be made aware of that
registration
requirement
I think the way the legislation is
worded is
that
the forest uh agency the relevant Forest
agency will require that this form be
submitted and then it's public
information it goes into a u file of sim
ilar just a followup maybe a little
confusion Mr chairman what what I'm
saying is so I own uh 500 acres of land
someplace in New Hampshire and I decide
I want to put it into a carbon um
capture program uh how am I made aware
that I have to file something with the
state on that how do I even know this
exists I guess in the same way that
anyone would become aware of other laws
that get passed by the state and
followup go ahead is there any there's
no mention of a size limit nor is there
in the bill 795 that I was referencing
so if somebody has four acres of land
and they decide they want to put it into
carbon capture a private person um
they're supposed to somehow track down
this law and file it and if they don't
file is there any punishment because I
see nothing about here if someone
doesn't file that there would be a fine
or something else you you are correct
there is no punishment in this
particular
statute I don't know what other
inforcement statutes may be in
chance Mr Hackley yeah sorry I got your
name wrong do you have any enforcement
mechanisms to uh if you could come up to
the table and turn on the mic and let us
know what you have for and Mr chairman
just to clarify again there doesn't seem
to be a size limit in this so is if I
have uh like I say if I have four acres
and I'm a dedicated California carbon
lover so I decide to buy carbon credits
uh am I supposed to report this or is it
a minimum of 500 Acres or
whatever now it looks to me like the
legislation specifies that um you would
report your acreage as part of the form
that the agency will create but Mr
Hackley if you could explain if you have
any enforcement
Powers we we have none relative to this
amendment as proposed we were not
involved in the drafting so didn't have
time to discuss that okay thank
you Vice chair Thomas uh thank you Mr
chair uh so
uh previous representative's comments
begs the question uh of the carbon
capture program would it even be econom
IAL or worth the effort for such a small
amount of acreage to be involved in that
program in other words what what's the
actual practicality of of who would sign
up uh if you have four acres is that too
little uh so is there someone out there
that can say that no one would even dare
uh join the program unless they had a
certain number of Acres anyway just for
economics
purpose interesting question don't know
the answer rep representative liwicki uh
thank you Mr chairman I would think that
the Registries of deeds and the real
estate lawyers would become aware of
this if the we if the word trickles down
to the Registries of Deeds then they
would uh obviously be able to uh inform
people of it I would think when when
made okay we have hard copies now of the
amendment
oh I will pass that out pass these out
to
everybody so uh representative licki I
was distracted there for a moment could
you repeat your
question that yes um I would think that
if we were to do this the Registries of
Deeds would be able to promulgate the
word and the real estate lawyers are you
know would then get the word
also I think you you're right and I'd
remind everybody that I think the
purpose of this amendment is to get us
started in trying to form some kind of a
response to a relatively new development
that is beginning to affect New
Hampshire Forest lands this is all very
new
and representatives from the North
Country came to us and said this is a
problem we have a potential solution the
moratorium that wasn't a real
solution so
we talked to a bunch of people a bunch
of stakeholders and came up with this as
a starting point to get uh something
moving forward that could find a
long-term solution to this problem
eventually this is a short-term solution
or the first step in a long-term
solution so I think that's all we can
expect from this amendment but I do
think it's a good first start
representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman um so the
first section of the bill instructs the
Department of Revenue Administration to
review uh conduct a study on the issues
related to Lost uh Timber attac Revenue
which I think is certainly appropriate
um I believe that Mr hackley's uh
participation or attempted participation
in the hearings um for his Department
suggest that perhaps uh th this
amendment might want to include uh his
division of forest and lands as well in
these conversations around what is going
on with the changing you know the
changing economics of forest land in New
Hampshire because I think he ultimately
would be required to help administer
this if I'm understanding uh correctly
with the registry and and also um he has
a better understanding if there are
going to be any cut offs in terms of the
amount of land that that should be
affected or reviewed or um that you know
he would have probably the appropriate
input there whereas Dr may not so I I
would just suggest that perhaps we could
um add language to include that
department uh in the study rather than
thought thank you uh representative
Kaplan
yeah thank you Mr chair um I agree with
uh representative Harrington's view that
the underlying bill 79.5 is a little bit
troubling in terms of telling people
what to do with their land and their
resources but I don't see any mention of
that Statute in in the in in the first
section so am I right or am I wrong that
that is not really uh you know you are
correct there is no mention of 795 thank
you representative Ms thank you Mr chair
um I would I just did a little quick
Google search and there is a um family
forest carbon program that covers Maine
New Hampshire Vermont New York
Massachusetts and one of their
eligibility requirements is that you
must own 30 or more Acres of non-planted
naturally regenerating trees on a
property so so to representative I think
it was Harrington's Point um we probably
should put something in there about a um
a a minimum and this is just one program
but they clearly aren't looking to pick
up people like the 4 acre example that
mentioned uh representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair uh further
to that point of of size I think we
heard in the testimony that there was
the possibility that several small land
owners with 2 3 4 58 acers would get
together and aggregate uh their forested
uh properties and then offer them as a
group so that's another possibility to
amendment well seeing none I guess we're
all done discussing this
amendment uh it has been suggested that
we
add the forestry folks to section one
although if I'm the Department of
Revenue Administration and I've been
tasked with conducting a study related
to Lost Timber tax revenue I think one
of the first people I'm going to go talk
to is the folks in the
U the agency that's responsible
for Timber tax and all that so I'm not
sure that language is
needed and with regard to specifying
some kind of an acreage in order to
be required to to make a filing for this
public
registry as representative Bernardi
pointed out if you can aggregate
small
Parcels then I don't think we need to
specify a minimum acreage level I think
we should just keep track of all the
land and the AG acreages would be one of
the things that's specified in the
registry so all that information would
be there and that that's the purpose of
the registry is to compile information
about Forest lands that might someday be
used for this purpose representative
Thomas um just a point of clarification
or just I'm asking for clarification
this AG ation program is that is that
currently in effect or is it anticipated
to be in effect at some
point I don't know of any existing
aggregations but I don't know of
anything that would prevent them either
right okay
thanks representative Harrington yeah I
I don't keep Haring on the point but I
just think that whether you aggregate or
don't aggregate I think if we look to
the people that are involved in this
thing they're not concerned about
someone's 5 acre lot that's not being
cut uh whether it's not being cut for
example my 5 acre lot is not being cut
and then 795 probably at least half of
it would qualify to uh be forced Timber
tax uh but no one's doing that because
it's a 5 acre lot um so I do think
realistically we ought to set some type
of a limit on this and say you know uh
acreage even if we want to say
aggregated or or or single Lots uh in
excess of 100 acres because I don't
think anyone's worried about the 5 acre
so representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um we received you know a bunch
of information electronically and one of
them was the proposed form from the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration notice of intent to cut
wood or
Timber um and the suggestion that a 58
be added for acreage of lot and acreage
of cut and so it's suggesting that that
um collection of data be added to this
form but that would only be if you were
intent to cut right so is it is it still
going to help us uh in terms of pulling
together a registry because if someone
isn't isn't doing sustainable forestry
and isn't cutting the wood how would we
know I mean I guess I'm just wondering
how hard it's going to be to to pull
together a comprehensive registry uh if
this is the only place we're collecting
that
data so on line 14 of the amendment it
says that there will be establishment
and maintenance of a public registry
listing Forest lands located within New
Hampshire that are enrolled in one or
more carbon
programs so if there is a 30 acre men
minimum for example to enroll on a
carbon program then you wouldn't have
to be listed in this registry
right
so I think this language is adequate but
I'm open to language changes if anybody
wants to suggest some
so representative months so that that
that that's a good point Mr chairman I
mean what this bill is really doing is
tracking land that has already been
enrolled in a program and and I think
your point is is accurate I mean if if
the program requirements are 30 acres
exactly any further discussion Mr
Hackley certainly come up come up to the
table and share with us your
perspective I know this might be out of
De Quorum for someone come in in a work
session but I see you're struggling with
the reason why we're doing this so if
we're going to go through this and our
agency is going to collect this data it
it needs to be as meaningful and useful
as
possible and I hear the discussion about
acreage limitations and as you learned
from Mr L when he gave his presentation
on carbon 101 the voluntary Market has
all kinds of requirements you can have
10 acres you can have 30 Acres there's
different minimums what we're trying to
quantify here in this trend toward Wards
carbon credit programs is the total
number of
Acres so whether you've enrolled five
acres or 500 Aces this registry should
try to capture that because that's what
we're trying to quantify is how many
landowners are engaged in carbon credit
programs and how many acres are enrolled
that's how we we look at Trends in the
forest products industry and in in the
forestry Community is is about acreage
so if you put a limit on it and saying
well you don't have to file in the
registry because you're you're under 30
Acres we're going to lose that data
we're going to lose the the trend that
may we don't know where this is going if
it's going to be you know like Gang
Busters or if it's just going to fizzle
under its own weight of credibility but
at the for now if we're going to make a
registry let's make sure that we collect
data that's meaningful and so that's why
I urg the chair and I I'm grateful for
him to include the number of Acres
actually it's the number of Acres
enrolled so if you own 100 acres you
might only want to enroll 50 acres so
that's what we want to know you've
you've enrolled a portion of your tax
lot so that again we're we're looking at
Trends total amount of acres per Town
Per County and per state so that we can
make informed policymaking should we
need to regarding the tax question that
is the first part of this amendment is
that helpful chairman so you would like
us to change the language in on line 25
to say acreage of subject land
enrolled that would be more specific and
it would help because otherwise I think
the land owner might just say oh well my
tax lot is 250 Acres I'm just going to
say 250 Acres but that's not necessarily
accurate if they've only enrolled 100
acres or 200 Acres see what I'm saying I
do do you have any other
suggestion changes to this amendment do
you need a copy uh thank you um
I I think that's the the the main thing
I mean we're going to have to uh Draft
rules for this but I do think the
notification process that was brought up
by um one of the committee members is an
important one how are land owners going
to know about this um many timber land
owners know about intent to cut and that
they have to pay Timber taxes but we may
need to um come up with a means of
communicating through the towns that a
new law has been passed if this in fact
makes it all the way through and becomes
law so a notification process is an
important aspect of this to the land
owners
um and maybe an annual report that we
put out each year that the number of
acres per County per state are X and
there are this many land owners engaged
in carbon credit programs again it's
about getting meaningful information
this is what the original sponsors of
this bill were looking for is like they
don't know who's involved in carbon
credits they don't know how many acres
are involved how is this going to impact
their Timber tax revenue
so let's make sure it's as helpful as
possible agreed so section two of the
227-4481
does this give you enough legal
authority to create a
rule to notify land owners that they
this I think it does um thank you for
um I would want to check with my staff
right now as far as you know we weren't
around when they tent to cut law was put
into play so I'm not sure how they
actually got that word out but I think
we can work with um the stakeholders in
this and maybe the New Hampshire
Municipal Association to um get that
word out that this is a new requirement
of Timberland owners okay
good representative muns uh thanks Mr
chairman if I could ask a follow-up
question
um do you do you feel that you need to
have that there needs to be some penalty
for non-compliance
provision and if so do you have the
statutory authority to do that through
Ru making or do you need us to put
something in there that specifically
says what that penalty would
be so I'm still new to the uh
legislative process here but I would
think that you would need to have some
some teeth in the law to enable rulle
making to have a penalty I don't I don't
know that for sure I would defer to all
of you but
um uh whatever the the penalty we have
in the current RSA 79a the timber tax
law if whatever that penalty is maybe we
can emulate that but um this is just a
reporting requirement it's not a tax
collecting document like the intent to
cut form is is all about taxes so I
would think we wouldn't need to make it
an orous penalty but I think we you know
if we're going to do this we should put
some teeth in in the enforcement aspect
whether that's in the body of the law or
say I'd be reluctant to put any
enforcement mechanism in here beyond
what the agency thinks they can do via
Ru
making paragraph B on line 26 says that
the landowner shall no ify the
municipality or municipalities where the
subject land is
located and once they understand that
they're supposed to do that I think most
would further discussion representative
Thomas yes um thank you
um so there's been um I'm sorry there's
been a discussion about an annual report
um which I think is a great idea if
we're going to collect this information
then then let's publish it somewhere um
the purpose of the annual report however
is just to collect the information or is
it to somehow suggest a change because
go I don't think there is an annual
report required based on this no that
was a suggestion from from the the
speaker that was a suggestion I made
just so that that it can be used by
policy makers or uh members of the the
forest products industry and Community
um again if we're trying to track a
trend that's just um something that
would be easily quantifiable at the end
of the
year but it's it's not something I'm
gonna I'm gon to die on that Hill
for I have I have a followup if we do
include it in I'm sorry if we do include
an annual report does that now um does
this now need a fiscal note because of
that
it might yeah
um so thank you that yes I would suggest
that if this information is publicly
available anybody can go get
it so we don't really need to file a
report let's see how this works out for
a year or
two if if it turns out to be a really
big deal and it needs a lot more
bureaucratic support then maybe we'll
pass some
new legislation to support it later but
I think this is a good place to start
get this thing going and see it see if
it's useful if it's not useful we might
scrap it all together
but it's important to get something
started today I think or as quickly as
possible so that we can start down the
road to figuring out how to handle this
situation Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chair uh actually I was just about to
say the same words as you did because
this bill is too important to the timber
indry particularly in the North country
but all over the state to let uh you
know perfect be the enemy of the good
and so I think to your point uh this
amendment looks like it's good enough to
get passed I have no doubt that our
friends on the other side of the wall
will make some comments when once they
get it and in the end we'll we'll come
up with a uh a statute that uh can is
workable and to your point uh maybe in a
year or two when things settle down uh
there'll be some adjustments but for
right now I think it's too important not
get going uh to to to just get this on
board all right so let's have a show of
hand of Representative McGee oh thank
you Mr chair I just it's just one little
knit um we had discussed
adding enrolled in carbon credits um
under number six acreage of subject land
but
um it it looks like number three above
uh where it's listing uh it says the
name of the program the program registry
or Registries under which the subject
land is enrolled so I think it's already
covered in the language and of course Mr
Hackley didn't have the copy at the time
so I'm not sure we need to add any
language there I think I think it's
already
covered thank you I'm glad you caught
that and I agree it is already
covered so do we need any further
discussion of this
amendment let's have a show of hands of
amendment okay that's
then next up will be House Bill H B
1078 relative to first responder
organization access to wireless tower
collocation Mr chairman my mistake
actually we're going to deal with House
Bill 1472 first relative to rebates of
Energy Efficiency funds for electric
vehicles because there are parties here
who would like to hear our discussion
but who have to leave so we will we will
do this one next
and I will open things up to
representative
muns thank you Mr chairman um and um you
know you should have an amendment that I
um circulated um last week it's uh
42h um what the amendment is attempting
to do is provide a little bit more
specificity uh as to what the intent of
the original bill was um during
testimony on the bill we um we heard
testimony and there were some questions
from members of the committee that it
might that it would be worthwhile to
have some guidelines and guard rails
around the program so that we were we
knew exactly what we would be doing if
this program was enacted and that's what
this amendment attempts to do um it uh
CL clarifies that we're talking about a
million5 dollar a year that would be
transferred um from the um the the the
the Reggie funds uh to support um a
program um each year for the next two
years um uh it also specifies that the
um that the rebate program would um be
that would apply to um electric vehicles
and plug-in hybrid
vehicles um up to $80,000 for a pickup
truck and up to $50,000 for all eligible
Vehicles it would include new and used
vehicles um the incentive for battery
electric vehicles would be $2,000 a
one-time payment of $2,000 and for
plugins it would be
$1,000 and to be eligible for the
program you would need to be a New
Hampshire resident at least 18 years of
age um with a valid New Hampshire
driver's
license um and the program would be set
up and and there are Income Limits um on
what the participant can make that are
consistent with what the federal
program's limits are and the program
would be set up in such a way that um a
participant could take the rebate
themselves or transfer it
to um the dealer and then the dealer
could take the price off of the um the
retail price of the uh the
vehicle
um the
um you know the the the money for this
would come from Reggie funds that are
currently being allocated towards
um a reduction in the El electric rates
for people and I know that's a concern
of um some members of the
committee um and I I did some math and
it looks like the the annual impact on a
customer would of this program by
diverting a million and a half dollars
would be about $2 per customer per
year um it's important to remember that
the money that would be used for this
program would still go to New Hampshire
residents um only New Hampshire
residents
um and um this program has the support
of the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association and it's the thing that
they've been asking for and it would um
help to um uh stimulate sales of
electric vehicles in New Hampshire
benefiting our local businesses and also
um you know we continue to struggle with
the um chicken in the egg issue
of um you know Chargers versus vehicles
and um by hopefully increasing the
number of vehicles on the road um this
will um you know stimulate the demand
for additional charging stations which
will then hopefully stimulate demand for
more um Vehicles so um I think it's a
it's a good small investment in um our
New Hampshire economy and um hoping that
uh people in the committee can support
the
additional comments representative
Kennedy uh thank you Mr chairman uh my
comments are more kind of on a policy
level the electrical vehicle tax credit
was first introduced as part of the
energy Policy Act of
2005 as a way to encourage the
production and Adoption of electric
vehicles in 2009 the American Recovery
and reinvestment act expanded the credit
to include plug-in electric vehicles and
$7,500 my question is how long do we
need to keep encouraging them we have
been doing this for 14
years the richest man in the world sells
EVS does he really need more
help at this point what these programs
accomplish in my
opinion is to take money from the
person's stocking shells at home Depot
and give it to some well-paid
professional so that he can boast to his
friends that he is saving the Earth and
I think that's
wrong further discussion representative
Thomas thank you um I would like to ask
of the Amendments author um is this
rebate program like the NH saves when it
runs out of money it runs out of
money yes there's a cap of $1.5 million
per year and this is just a pilot
program yeah thank
you further discussion representative
lii uh thank you Mr chairman um like
many things I think that if voluntary
would be better than mandatory and why
not if we are to do it to have poor Paul
who's paying the bill be able to check
off on his electric bill that he wants
to contribute to a fund rather than uh
making every making all the uh stalkers
at U Home Depot pay for um rich
people further
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chair um my comment my thought is
that uh I think since I've been on the
committee uh this my third term we have
had uh many bills and many proposals to
try and take the money that the state
receives from the regional greenhouse
gas Initiative Program and figure out uh
ways to help lower our emissions
basically uh do something that helps uh
on the carbon side and that is the
intent of that program and yet we are
the only state that still diverts a
majority of the money to rebates and I
think that's a decision of the
legislature but I think um I think where
this bill is coming from in in my
understanding from talking with the
original Bill sponsor is that we are
looking to try and use that money for a
bit of an economy of scale to do
something a little larger it's the same
thing with the new New Hampshire saves
program which is the only program you
know the Energy Efficiency fund is the
only program that we have authorized and
we've received information over the
years that because of those Investments
we've been able to stabilize our demand
um because we're doing demand side
demand side investment um so it's really
a question of what we're getting getting
back for what is a relatively small
investment and also it it is assisting
you know the Dealers Association uh to
remain competitive because at this point
if people are interested in test driving
or um you know having access to seeing
what it would like be like to have an
electric vehicle people are going to
other states uh to to have those test
drives and they they don't have an easy
time finding electric vehicles here so I
think this program would be able to help
transition thank you representative
Harrington thank you Mr Speaker well
first I'd like to say it certainly is no
shock that the automobil uh deals
Association is in favor of this I mean
what business wouldn't be if you're
going to come out and say we're going to
give $1,000 to your customers in order
to buy your product well you know be
have to be an idiot not to be in favor
of that but we also must remember where
this money comes from it's we talk about
Reggie money being returned this is
money that the rate payers pay they're
charged every penny of the Reggie money
comes from rate payers then in some
states they use it on different programs
in New Hampshire most of it's rebated
back to the rate payers to defer it we
always talk about electric bills but
every time something like this comes up
it's only $2 or of this or it's only $4
whatever but you know eventually all
these things tend to add up I refer to
this type of Bill as a reverse Robin
Hood bill because you have someone out
there that's making $60
$70,000 which is around the the medium
income I think 75,000 in New Hampshire
they're not buying a electric vehicle
even with $1,000 CU they can't afford to
go out and spend $440,000 for a car so
that doesn't make any difference to them
but on the other hand if you have a a
married couple that are making jointly
$290,000 they're going to get $2,000
towards their nice new electric pickup
truck uh this is simply taking from the
people that don't have and given to the
people that have it's not a m matter of
everybody can take advantage of this
because like I said a huge portion of
our population will not be able to
afford electric vehicle even with a
$1,000 R uh
rebate representative parshall has a qu
a
comment thank you chair I'm starting to
resent the uh um characterization of uh
this is being a giveaway to the rich I
this purchased my second elect El
vehicle and a big motivator in that
purchase was the fact that I did get a
federal rebate on that purchase the
purchase itself was under
$155,000 it's going to save me
significant money in my gas at at the
pump and it's going to hopefully if we
believe in the free enterprise system
it's going to drive the price of
gasoline
down and to be characterized this as a
giveaway to the rich is an extremely
offensive characterization of this
bill representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman uh to representative parshall's
comments I would also uh remind everyone
that this uh rebate would apply to used
EVS as long as they're bought through a
dealer so you're going to be see seeing
lower prices on those Vehicles so it's
not really entirely for the rich uh and
also to address some of the other
comments we're in this point of
technological change and technological
change is rarely easy when we started
replacing horses with
automobiles not everybody could afford
an automobile and gasoline was hard to
come by you had to go to to a pharmacy
and buy it by the pint or court so we're
in that sort of situation now and the
question is do we want to promote that
sort of change or do we want to stifle
it Vice chair Thomas has a comment thank
you Mr chair uh respectfully I would
like to remind uh representative Corman
that the example cited uh it was true
but it was Private Industry that was
able to get people to finally get more
gas out there uh and to sell more of
their gas powered vehicles it wasn't any
legislative subsidy or mandates and to
this point here I I know they were
private Industries they big private
Industries they spent a lot of money
doing that setting up their own gas
stations but I think to this point here
is is that U I firmly believe let the
market decide let just let the market
decide if people want and can afford a
vehicle they will buy it and so uh and
that's where I think we are particularly
to have people that are paying electric
bills to pay for people to buy electric
vehicles I don't think is the right
vehicle anyway so it's my point on
that representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman yes I just
wanted to
um I guess uh join in um support um my
colleague representative parshall's
remarks and you know push back on the
characterization that this would be uh
just a subsidy for the rich um while
it's true
that uh some models of electric vehicles
you know your Teslas your rivan are on
the expensive side there's also Al the
Chevy bolt which is the bestselling e
and which is a very low priced uh you
know little four-door hatchback um
that's very accessible to U A lot of
people and I would like to point out
that the focus on the sticker price is
also misplaced um while and and in fact
the the policy instrument of the rebate
uh The Upfront you know uh first cost
rebate is is well established the cost
advantage of electric vehicles is in
their ownership ownership costs they
have much lower cost of fuel and
maintenance and
so
um folks on the lower end of the
income you know wealth
Spectrum
um well it's true that they might have a
hard time affording the first cost of an
EV if they can if they can get
one um they'll have a much easier time
with uh with the ownership costs and so
that's that's why the rebate um that's
you know a premise of New Hampshire
saves is you you give people a incentive
to buy this more
efficient energy using item so that they
can have lifetime cost savings and so SU
Society can have lifetime pollution
savings from the Efficient Electric
Vehicle so that's where we're try we're
this representative uh
Harrington um just a a quick search here
um higher income households earning over
$100,000 a year account for 56% of EV
owners only 4% of EV owners have a house
so income under 25,000 so again the
people making under 25,000 are still
paying electric bills so they're
subsidizing the rich people if you look
at some other statistics on this was
2021 there was a later one for
California that said the average income
of uh EV owners was over
$150,000 so to think that this is going
to be you know the the poor lower inome
people they're just not going to be able
to take advantage of this they're just
going to see the
bill representative McGee thank you Mr
chair um um I would like to go back to
Reggie for a moment because um in the
reports that I've seen over the years
and in the data that I've looked at in
terms of the amount of income that's
been going to us and the other states
that are participating in the region um
that money it's a cap and trade program
designed to give us economies of scale
by providing money through the sale of
credits from large emitting plants and
businesses so there's a track backing of
their emission and there's a credits
program that they're required to
participate in it is not rate payer
funding and so so the fact that no one
else is doing rebates back to rate
payers uh from that money and that they
are using it to get their states ahead
in terms of Investments on lowering
emissions um it it really says something
about how we view the program so I just
want to put out there that this bill is
just one example this term of us trying
to say that some of that money should be
used to advance uh lowering emissions in
the
state representative Bernardi has a
comment thank you Mr chair uh as uh
representative Kennedy uh
articulated uh I I agree philosophically
with that approach I am philosophically
against this concept and one of the
things that we asked in a uh hearing
last week was when the uh utilities
created uh their their plans uh for the
uh ex uh maintenance and growth of their
system in the future that they they
identify that part of the growth in the
distribution Network that is tied to the
need to expand it with additional wiring
and additional Transformers to support
support uh the EV Market uh I I think
it's it's uh inappropriate that the rate
payers be paying higher electric bills
for a building out of the distribution
system when they don't own an EV
themselves we seem to be debating the
bill itself rather than discussing the
amendment
so I'm going to try
to redirect the conversation a little
bit
by commenting on line one of page
two which speaks of
returning or federal income tax returns
of $300,000 for married couples filing
jointly $225,000 for heads of households
and 150,000 for all other
filers
and I'm concerned about the Optics of
asking someone who pays who makes
$118,000 a year and yes I know people
who live on $188,000 a year asking them
to pay more for electricity so that
someone making 300 225 or
$150,000 can get a rebate to buy an
electric vehicle so I'm wondering would
uh changing those dollar amounts
lowering those dollar
amounts um be
worthwhile for this
amendment Mr chairman representative mut
um I believe it's Maine um they actually
their program actually has numbers that
are uh exactly half of what the federal
amounts
are and um you know I I share your
concern about the Optics um and if that
is a change that um would make this uh
Amendment more agreeable I'd certainly
not be opposed to
it so then the question becomes well
what is an agreeable
level
um I would argue that maybe 75,000 for
married
couples and 50,000 for head of
households
and maybe 30,000 for all other flyers
filers might be uh more appropriate what
think representative
um it sounds a little bit low but um if
that's what it would take to get your
support um I would be I would be
agreeable to that that would be in the
spirit of my remarks earlier that said
you know the low priced electric vehicle
can really help the uh lower income
family and and if that's what we would
want to um see happen where we'd want to
put our policy emphasis I'd be I'd be in
support the real question is would it be
effective representative
Thomas um I don't have the answer to
that question but what I was going to
comment on is that um home deep workers
seem to be um twice now they've been
sort of demonized as being destitute
workers uh my father-in-law works for
Home Depot and he would love an
opportunity like this and he would take
advantage of it because he sees the
whole picture the big picture just want
to put
a for Home Depot
workers okay representative MC
Williams thanks chair Vose um I I do
think that we could reduce the amount um
I think that 75,000 for married couples
is low um I think you're more likely to
get 75,000 for head of household so
instead of 50,000 for head of household
I would say 75,000 per head of household
married couples um I think we probably
want to just pull a little bit more data
about what the the average is and also
what we consider to be lowincome in
terms of being able to qualify for um
some kind of state support uh because I
think 75,000 may not actually Encompass
the higher range of lwi income in New
Hampshire I would probably think that's
closer to 85 possibly 95 but I can get
some more data on that for you I just
wouldn't want to exclude people who
otherwise would be included under other
metrics by throwing out a number that's
a quarter of the uh Federal
amount representative
Arrington uh yeah two things I wanted to
correct a statement made earlier on
Reggie uh it it's a cap and trade
program that's correct but the money
comes directly from the rate payers
because the Reggie program forces uh
producers of electricity that use fossil
fuels most of the case we're talking
about natural gas which sets the the
price of electricity to pay a higher
price they pay a penalty for that and
that penalty of course is directly pay
passed on to the rate payers so every
Reggie penny comes from the rate payer
so this would definitely be rate payer
money second this is still a wealth uh
transfer program I don't care if you put
the limited 50,000 or 100,000 or 5,000
it's simply not up to the government to
be taking money from one person and
giving it to the other because some
people think electric cars are a good
idea if you think electric cars are a
good idea go buy one if you want to give
someone else money to buy an electric
car give them your money but I I will
not support anything no matter what the
limits are on expanding another program
to take the government to forcibly take
money from one group and give it to
another because somebody thinks it's a
good idea representative n has a comment
I concur with representative
Harrington representative
Corman thank you and actually this is a
question for uh my friend representative
muns which is there's nothing in here
about people who lease
EVs and I would think that many people
are releasing EVS in large part because
they are concerned that the technology
is is improving so fast that they don't
want to be quote stuck with an EV for
several years and it might be better to
lease one for three years and then get a
an upgraded model with longer range
faster charging uh was there any thought
given to
leasing representative Ms first I want
to thank my friend representative Corman
for you know posing that challenging
question to me
um there was no specific discussion of
of leasing but since leasing is
basically a way of financing a vehicle I
would assume that you know that would
that would qualify uh but that is an
assumption you know what they say about
assume um and since I have the mic I
wanted to just clarify something when I
mentioned that uh there were lower
standards in Maine it's actually
Massachusetts that has the lower
standards um and I also agree with
representative mc mc Williams that I
think the levels that you're proposing
Mr chair are probably a little bit too
low representative
PL uh thank you chair I had a question
which I withdrew when you brought us
back to the amendment and now that we
brought back I'd like to thank you for
trying to be the idea of bipartisanship
but I won't be voting for this amendment
because this does have this does nothing
to l lower our electrical rates which is
one the highest
nor um level the demand this might even
increase demand issues we the Peaks and
valleys this does not help and those are
two reasons and I won't be supporting
this thank
you representative rals thank you Mr
chairman I just hopefully can be helpful
about representative corman's question
and about the uh applicability of a
rebate to the lease
I think our
bill we maybe we should just we should
specify but that's the way the federal
tax credit in fact can work uh I bought
an electric vehicle I leased it uh you
basically can apply the lease uh the the
rebate the the federal tax credit to a a
buy down of the
price uh so the dealer
gets gets the you know in this case ,000
and
then the lease amount that the customer
has to pay is
reduced so it it works it can it can be
applied either as a credit on the
purchase or a buy down of the lease
amount which then the lease Lor
experiences the benefit over the benefit
term of the
lease this is a cash on the hood program
for a point of sale electric vehicle
rebates to buyers that would seem to
preclude leasing as a financing method
wouldn't it we probably ought to modify
if we go
forward further comments representative
parall thank you chair I heard earlier
that uh it's not the role of government
to uh take money from one group of
people and give it to another I think
that's a
constitutional provision that taxation
is part of our system and we do this all
the time I don't think this is something
new that we're Reinventing as a means of
robbing poor people to give money to
rich people I think it's quite the
opposite but I would also add that when
it comes to that money we just lost $15
million because of our inability to move
on charging
stations
um of the of our New Hampshire citizens
tax dollars going to the federal level
we should have had that money coming
back into New Hampshire and it's law and
it's turning our back on the EV industry
repeatedly that causes us to not get
this kind of federal support which loses
us real money in New Hampshire we're not
serving the taxpayers of New Hampshire
when we pass laws that make the EV
Market unfriendly and I would also add
one other thing to uh representative
pl's comment if I may um I'm very
excited about de um decentralizing our
grid and one of the ways we can do it is
by getting Battery Technology into the
home and if we have more EVS e EVS are
easily designed to uh charge at night
when demand is low and they can even
return that charge during the day
lowering the curve low our demand curve
which is I think a concern that we both
have so I really think that this would
probably be a benefit rather than a uh
deficit to our uh
grid thank you further discussion on
Amendment
0342 representative
McWilliams um so just coming back to the
numbers chair Vos uh it looks like
Massachusetts uh had some really good
reasons for including the income at the
levels that they did for lower income
and getting people who otherwise uh may
not be able to purchase an EV because
they can't financially afford it to
participate in the program and I
certainly hear your concerns and the
concerns of some of my other colleagues
around this table uh in terms of people
who are at the higher end of the income
Spectrum should be able to purchase
without an incentive and perhaps we
should be focusing a little bit more on
people who need the help um so I would
say that going with the Massachusetts
guidelines is probably at this point
knowing what we know a reasonable step
for an amendment to the amendment so
that we are targeting folks who
otherwise may not be able to and not
opening up wider to people who could
take advantage without actually needing
the benefit so for that reason I would
support an amendment to the amendment
and I would hope that I could get your
Vose additional discussion on the
amendment representative lewicki um Mr
chairman I don't disagree with um
changing limits however it seems clear
to me that we are going to send this out
a committee with a mixed recommendation
and uh whatever the dollar amounts are
additional
discussion okay seeing none I think we
can move on from this uh piece of
proposed
legislation and folks who uh wanted to
attend this uh work session to uh move
on to other things yes representative Ms
um B based on you know where we kind of
left that I mean I'd be I'd be happy to
submit an amendment request to lower
those amounts I'll bring that to the
meeting this
afternoon okay you can do
that now let's talk about House Bill
1078 relative to first responder
organization access to wireless tower
collocation and this is another bill for
which we have an
amendment the amendment
is
H and the amendment is sponsored by
representative Bernardi who will explain
US Representative n do you have
something first um yes representative PR
wanted to be here for this one he had to
run to Edna do you mind if I go fetch
do while she does that I'll ask uh
representative Bernardi to make a few
General remarks
about uh the need for
this amendment and then maybe by the
time representative PR returns you can
talk about some of the details of the
amendment representative Bernardi thank
you Mr chair well uh there's not a lot
to say about this amendment we discussed
it fairly thoroughly
um in our last working session the issue
that came up was the fact that the
original
Bill cited RSA 12
K1 when it was
amended
OS changed the RSA
chapter
appropriately to 21
P38 but the Lang anguage at the top of
the bill where it says this bill amends
X to Y whatever never got changed
so um what has been done
is have have OS correct that
deficiency basically saying amend the
the bill by replacing in its entirety
the enacting clause and and and then the
same language that we discussed last
last week is what remains in in lines 22
to
25 which basically reflects the fact
that uh and recognizes the fact that we
have gaps in both radio and Broadband
communication coverage for police fire
and other First Responders and we need a
mechanism to fix them what had been
proposed in the original bill was to get
access to the tops
of uh Towers uh or new towers um that
are being installed old towers that
exist and there may be some space or
whatever um that was deemed not an
appropriate
uh Bill and and so what this bill does
is first examine um where the gaps are
and then secondly make
recommendations on various strategies to
fix those problems it's as simple as
that okay on a discussion on the
amendment
0438 representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um regarding this amendment and I I
believe it's a wrong Amendment I'm not
opposed to it but the department of
safety opposed the original Bill have
you um connected with them regarding
this amendment at
all yes they were involved in in this in
this uh and their their opposition well
they declared neutrality but I would
agree that tended to be a somewhat
negative
neutrality um but uh um and and there
wasn't an original earlier Amendment
where where we had asked the department
of safety to actually do the engineering
studies regarding the gaps uh and I
think they um came to the table that one
they didn't have those resources and it
wasn't in the current budget so this
bill allows a budgetary cycle to pick up
on whatever strategies and
recommendations may be forthcoming and
then potentially be budgeted for
remedies in the future okay thank you
representative Harrington and thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
I just wanted to make sure kind of
looking at this it seems to be pretty
Common Sense Bill and straightforward
I'm just kind of surprised we're not
doing this that the Department of
Emergency uh management powers and uh
whatever they were called the division
of emergency services and communication
they're not already looking at things
like this as part of their routine
duties uh apparently they don't they
don't they don't focus on that
uh except when State Communications are
involved but when towns or cities have
gaps it is it doesn't rise to their
level of examination all right thank you
representative reels uh thank you Mr
chairman yeah I just um want
to thank representative Bernardi for
working on this amendment um seems to me
like a a similar situation to the the
earlier Bill we were talking about 1700
where original Bill sort of took a you
know flail at uh a solution to a problem
and probably wasn't the right solution
and um while this this bill is going to
instead uh have us have us the state um
go take a real look at the problem and
uh gather the information needed to
craft an actual solution to the problem
so uh good work and I'm going to be
supporting Vice chair Thomas thank you
Mr chair uh I agree and I fully support
this amendment the point I would like to
make is that this involves um in my
opinion critical safety Communications
with towns and counties and and also I'm
beginning to think that maybe uh
sometimes legislation may need to look
into things like this because in a
similar bill that we agreed to have inim
study on that pointed to a problem with
critical Communications that for some
reason were not being tended to in a
timely manner uh a little bit different
case but still it centers on
Communications which is what this bill
does as well so I would I I believe that
this is a good case of when we as
legislators need to find out what's
going out there in the commercial world
how come we're having some issues
occasionally with critical
Communications involving Safety First
Responders we need to uh NE not
necessarily make any mandates but we do
need to investigate and find out what
can be done to make this better so I
think this is a very important issue
that that's coming
discussion
seeing none I guess uh we're done with
our discussion and our work session on
House Bill
1078 and I get the sense from the
committee that this um Amendment and the
bill will move forward when we go to
afternoon so now we'll move on to house
bill 14 1987 relative to the health
effects of 5G
technology there are no amendments
proposed for this
legislation
and I will point out that the
original Bill directed the Department of
Environmental Services to do a bunch of
um communication about the effects of of
electromagnetic
radiation
and it would appear that the Department
of Health and services would have been
the more appropriate uh agency to deal
with that so I think the legislation is
essentially flawed and would have a
difficult time moving forward but I'm
interested to hear what other people
might have to say representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman uh regardless of
which agency is tasked
I I could not possibly support this I
feel
that there there are so many
requirements here that that I just don't
see them making any sense PSAs about the
health risks associated with radiation
we don't know those health risks um
requiring uh signage on every
pole uh of course the the idea of
eliminating Wireless within schools I
mean there's just so much here that is
entirely unworkable that there's no way
I could support this bill regardless of
which agency or agencies were
tasked representative
Harrington yeah yeah I'll have to agree
with everything was just said once again
so maybe something Good's going to
happen for the Celtics or something um
this is It's just impractical first of
all there's no FM on this and we've got
the Environmental Services climbing all
over all these polls and putting up
signs and I would assume this this is
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of Labor just to get this stuff done and
you know I sympathize with the people
who have this issue but this is not the
solution to it going this
way Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr chair
I totally agree this uh bill is
unworkable I'd like to point out that we
had a commission that came up with a
bunch of recommendations some time ago
and although they were studied those
recommended Solutions were deemed to be
um either unworkable or too expensive
and then we had a study committee done
to talk about the commission and another
bill that came forward and that study
committee came up with uh the near same
conclusion uh all only offering that
maybe towns uh may have a say on in
location of certain uh Towers if they
would go and find out how how they could
do those things and then we had here we
had testimon which really offered no new
information from the other two uh bills
that previously submitted so I I think
this uh there's a problem here we
understand people uh have some medical
issues uh that they do suffer from some
conditions uh but again there's just
correlation and causation don't seem to
be there enough to make this bill at all
workable so I I would be voting against
this bill as well representative nter
has passed out
a um passed out has passed out yeah
distributed a slide presentation that
she prepared the last time we had a 5G
Bill and uh she's provided a copy of
that for everybody just to refresh your
memory further discussion representative
fog thank you chair um I I won't be
supporting this bill even though I do
have questions about the 5G and from
people I have heard from but this bill
is unworkable thank you further
discussion representative Ms thank you
Mr chairman um I I've been I've been
struggling with this bill I mean I'll be
honest with you when I first heard it I
said no then no no way those
recommendations seem off the- wall and
then um
I was I was reminded via a article that
appeared in the Portsmouth Herald uh
yesterday that of of the 5G commission
and so I I pulled out the report and did
a
comparison and with the exception of the
well well no all of the recommendations
that are included in this bill were
included were were recommended by that
commission by the majority of that
commission and it was a bipartisan
commission headed Ed up by Patrick
abami and um you know stat
Representative Patrick abami who you
know is long serving
representative um and also um then state
senator Tom Dr Tom
Sherman and
um so I'm I'm struggling a little bit
with you know trying to respect the
process I mean we spent a lot of time
and effort putting together a
report and now there's a bill Implement
that report um so I don't I don't know
that I necessarily there isn't any real
conclusion that I'm drawing but um I'm
just sharing kind of my my thought
process that you know um a lot of people
spent a lot of more lot more time on
this than we did and are and came up
with these recommendations and now
law thank you further discussion
representative lewicki uh thank you Mr
chairman I think that if we're going to
do uh anything it's got to recognize the
things that are in Representatives not
as presentation which is power and
frequency the um that thing puts out 12
Watts um the laptops that I see open are
putting out some unknown number of watts
of power in the Wi-Fi right here in this
room um now are we going to stop that
are we going to start recognizing limits
can we say that you know some minimum
amount of power is um you know di
Minimus you know essentially at the
noise floor because without that this is
meaningless if somebody puts up a tower
and puts one of those things on top of
it um and that's all there is um is this
um the same as somebody putting up a
Watts representative
Kennedy thank you Mr chairman um i' just
like to make a comment to uh the
preceding comment which is that the the
effect on you know biological tissue
depends on frequency it does not depend
on power because a certain amount of
energy is delivered it's a photon and
that depends on frequency so that's
that's why there's always so much focus
on frequency because ultraviolet
radiation x-rays whatever they are of a
fre frequency where they can they can
deliver a photon which breaks chemical
bonds which ionizes molecules and those
are the things that do
damage representative
fog thank you chair yes I concur with
representative Ms the report does show a
lot but I go back to before I go here I
believe this is not
ended this issue will come back and
we'll see what when that happens but
once again this to myself this bill is
not
it representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair um I'm not going to beat a dead
horse but this bill although it may have
originated from some recommendations
from that committee goes all over the
place and it just it's trying to do too
much and in particular the the
requirement for schools to go to
hardwired equipment that um is going to
direct affect specialed kids that use
devices uh for communication and there's
no way I can support
this representative
Ms thank you Mr chair yeah I I probably
should have clarified some of my
comments I mean I I do I do agree with
representative Wendy Thomas that um the
provisions around requiring uh schools
moving away from Wireless that that to
me is definitely a step too far because
that has too too many implications and I
certainly wouldn't support the bill uh
just based on that um but I think a lot
of the other recommendations are really
about um you know kind of notification
and data collection um you know the
notifications are similar somewhat to
you know how we started um raising
awareness about tobacco products putting
a warning on cigarette packs um and you
know the other in the other some of the
other recommendations are very similar
to what we just talked about with the um
the the uh Forest Products registry it's
collecting data uh to see you know to
what extent is there a problem and
um you know as I said earlier I'm I I'm
still struggling with this but I I I
keep I keep recalling comments that I've
heard a number of people say is that you
know 10 years ago we didn't think P was
a problem and now it's generally
recognized as a problem and is this the
next p episode that we're going to be
dealing with and based on that is it
worthwhile at least letting people know
that this is going on without saying
that it's harmful or not but just that
it's happening and start collecting some
data we can probably put an end to your
struggles by pointing out that there is
no money appropriated by this
legislation to do the work that the bill
wants to do there's not even an FN
designation so we can't even send it to
finance and ask them to find some money
it's just not implementable the way it's
written representative
parshall thank you chair um somebody
smarter than my than me once said that
the uh most Savage controversies are
those about matters to which there's no
good evidence either way I still feel
that way about the way our regulation of
5G technology which is I think
representative keny pointed out
correctly that we are talking about
frequency we are not talking about power
I think it's a very accurate statement I
wish we had a good bill before us that
would delve into these issues free from
some of the uh junk science that is
sometimes attached to this I don't
believe this is that bill but I do
believe that uh the study committee came
up with some very specific regulations
and I will continue to support that
study committee and legislation that
does further the
investigation into these areas I think
investigation of know you what we're
doing is probably the best we can do at
this point Thank You representative
licki um yeah my I point out that if we
were to force all of the schools in the
state not only is it an unfunded mandate
but this would not cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars to rewire the
schools it would cost millions and uh we
would be dumping that on the local
budgets
additional
discussion seeing none I think we'll
move on next up is House
Bill 1508 requiring fiber optic
Communication service providers to
prioritize service restoration for
Public Safety and public health
organizations the prime sponsor of this
legislation recommended that we refer it
for interim study
which is a recommendation I think the
committee should seriously
consider open to discussion Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair yes this is
exactly the other bill I was talking
about uh talking about critical safety
Communications and I think uh absolutely
it's uh important enough to do into to
go into interim study uh to find out
what legislation if any uh might be
applicable to make sure
that even dealing with private uh firms
we need to make sure that critical
safety information Communications First
Responders needs are are always met and
so I think it's appropriate that we go
into interim study on
discussion representative Kennedy thank
you Mr chairman just a just a brief
comment but the representative who was
here for I can't remember exactly what
the organization was telephone associ
iation or something but you know she
pointed out that there there have been
protocols for prioritizing Public Safety
for a century so I don't know if we need
to study it or
discussion representative
Gman I actually agree with
representative Kennedy um uh it was
Teresa Rosenberger from the New
Hampshire telephone Association and
Consolidated communication
and she said they already have protocols
and this was really a customer service
issue and I don't see the need for us to
be involved I'm okay with interim study
but I don't think that's even
necessary further discussion
representative Harrington once again I
agree with my
colleague representative
Ms and this is really scary I agree with
representative
Harrington um I think it's definitely a
uh a customer service issue unfortunate
customer service issue but nevertheless
a customer service issue representative
n shocking even more shocking so I agree
with representative muns and
representative courtman all right all
right I'm piling on this one I agree
with representative n all right all
right Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair uh
respectfully I disagree with all the
others uh and the reason is this it's
not so much uh of what was mentioned but
one of the issues that came out during
uh public hearing was there appeared to
be no belly button specifically for the
um uh the town to call when they were in
this type of a situation uh suggestion
was made rightfully so that they could
put a complaint into the AG and perhaps
they could get around to it in a couple
of weeks or a month but the issue was
what happens when a situation like this
occurs and the police chief or next time
it could be a hospital or it could be
fire chief has to get action right now
there was no one that they were able to
go to that could put pressure or even
find out what the issue was outside of
calling the CEO of the company so I
think that in because of that issue is
why I support inm study is to find out
if if perhaps there might be something
that uh could be that could be put out
there or maybe information could be put
out there but uh in my opinion in
talking to the originator of the bill
and the police chief uh they were they
were given the runaround they was no
single point of contact that they could
go to to get something resolved
immediately and I think that's my
concern and I think that's why I think
Kum study might at least bring out
either suggestions or maybe none but I
think that's what I think that's why
interum studies appropriate in in this
case good point additional
discussion looks like we've run the
gamut on this one so let's move on to
the last bill that we will discuss
during this work session and that is
House Bill
1576 relative to allowing Property
Owners to opt out of Public
Utilities and we do have an amendment
for this
bill that amendment is
circulating as I speak it is 202
24-44
6h and it is
a replacement to
the uh original Bill
including on a replacement of the title
it changes the title of the bill from
relative to allowing Property Owners to
out opt of Public Utilities to the new
title which will be relative to suitable
building drainage and private water
sources it amends a completely different
section of existing
law and the amendment decreases the feet
distance requirement for con for
connecting to public sewers from 100 ft
to 20 ft
and it also prohibits the adoption of
the international public code Provisions
as they relate to private
Wells the bill also permits the
replacement of alternative sewage
Disposal Systems with other alternative
sewage Disposal Systems that are are in
compliance with state and local
regulations the prime sponsor of the
original
Bill thinks that this is a more
appropriate method to address the issue
of mandatory Su sewer
hookups which can be costly and have
other problems
for the average citizen so this is her
proposed solution I think it's workable
and I'd like the committee to consider
it representative reels has a comment
about the
amendment yes Mr chairman thank you and
I I do not note that you you are listed
um at the top of this sponsoring this
amendment but um all of that description
makes me wonder why is this being
considered by our committee because it
seems like a matter of sort of
Environmental Services water
quality um you know I sort of feel
unqualified to to um just whether this
is a good thing or a bad thing and since
it affects um
substantially you know it's kind of
almost like a municipal
code issue um you know has this been run
by the municipal Association uh what are
the effects going to be so just
wondering I take your point but the
simple answer to your question why do we
have this bill is because it was
originally signed to us assigned to us
and there is no method within house
rules I don't think of vacating a bill
once it's gone through a public hearing
and and reach this stage of the process
so we're stuck with it whether we like
it or not do we do we feel competent to
pass judgment on the substance I'm not
sure um that's what we're here to
discuss
so I'll uh look forward to hearing
comments and we'll start with Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair uh let me
address the first question first um the
reason was simple because the original
Bill had the word electricity in
there and so going going through the
process they you know had to make a
choice and it came to us and now it's
too late so that's that's uh that's why
we have it um I I support this amendment
um originally I I didn't think it was
something that we might want to do but
it seems like it's a workable Amendment
apparently I found out some towns may
have restrictions I found out recently
just last week that in my town of lary
there are no such restrictions we we
were talking uh profusely about our
water issue and about bringing in uh
public water down highways and I
specifically asked the question would
would anyone along that Corridor be
required to hook up and the answer was
absolutely not um so in my town we don't
have that uh restriction
uh in fact I Al also uh pleased to hear
that even people with Wells if they even
if they did hook up to town they would
still be able to use your wells for
Gardens and you know and and things like
that so uh I guess it's a town by Town
thing so um I think this amendment will
uh perhaps take care of some towns that
may have a little more restrictions than
than mine does just to clarify I think
this particular Amendment refers only to
sewer systems I don't think it talks
about water although the title
does
yeah the last
paragraph yeah and speaking of that last
private Wells okay all right
representative McWilliams had us comment
uh thank you chair Vose um this is very
similar to a couple of bills that I've
been working on over the last few years
at Edna um in terms of code requirements
and passing legislation that impacts
recommended code requirements so in the
state of New Hampshire we have the
building code review board which meets
frequently to review amendments to the
codes and has all kinds of process for
weighing in and doing custom amendments
um specifically the last paragraph in
this amendment is something that is
worthy of review and discussion by the
building code review board and the
reason I say this is because we are
historically famous in New Hampshire for
having small Lots that are individually
serviced by their own well and their own
septic and in New Hampshire we keep a
100 foot radius around an individual
well and we say you cannot have your
septic in that area because you do not
want the two mixing so my concern here
about creating a carve out so that the
IPC prohibiting private Wells that would
otherwise comply with state and local
regulations is that suddenly we're
pulling the rug out from underneath this
100 foot radius that protects people
from accidentally mixing sewage and well
water together that's no good you'll get
sick um so I I think that that's a
dangerous paragraph and it's something
the bcrb should review and and give full
input on if that's something that is
included in this overall discussion
about requiring toilets which I think
makes sense um allowing some kind of
historic alternative sewage yes we have
old cess pools um and perhaps we do have
composting toilets as well uh the 20
foot distance changing from 100 foot
distance but allowing towns to to go
back up to 100 foot I don't really see
that as a concern but you probably once
again want to get some uh Municipal
folks to weigh in on that because I
think that in certain towns that's a
dangerous thing to do when you have
small lot sizes um so overall I think
it's okay but I have real concerns about
the last paragraph
Thanks well I appreciate you bringing
that up but reading the language of the
says that the department shall not adopt
provision of the code that prohibit the
use of private
Wells which would otherwise comply with
state and local regulations so if the
100 foot radius that you talked about is
a state or a local regist
regulation
then wouldn't the private well have to
comply with
that um so we've changed the 100 foot to
20 feet throughout the first portion of
this so the state regulation is changing
to 20 ft meaning that the foot which is
currently best practice wouldn't apply
okay I see I see what you're saying now
um so that bears some investigation I
guess H further comments representative
Harrington yeah maybe I'm just not
reading this right but I read the 20 ft
to say that had to do with hooking up to
a septic to a public SE system so a
public soore so right now if you're
within 100 feet you have to hook up this
would say you have to hook up within 20
ft and unless I'm missing something I
don't see that has anything to do with
putting in a well uh closer to a a
septic system uh I don't know what the
international plumbing code is and does
anybody know why they someone wants this
provision in the law that says that but
but I don't think the 20 foot section
online 14 changes the distance between
septic system and Wells it changes the
distance the minimum distance where you
have to hook up to a public soore if
there's one within 20 ft rather than 100
that's way I'm reading it maybe I'm
reading it wrong but you seem to know
more about the international plumbing
code so she's an architect okay well
what is it that that someone's trying to
avoid any ideas I mean well we have
someone here from Dees who maybe can uh
shed some light on all this so please
come forward and uh
help us understand this issue it's kind
of out of our ballpark normally so any
light You Can Shed would be really
appreciated no sure I'm Brandon kernin
I'm the administrator of the drinking
water and groundwater Bureau I testified
with my colleague Tracy wood who's out
this week so and she represented
Wastewater but my program works a lot
with both sides of
it thank you so in looking through the
bill we definitely as a department have
a lot of concerns about changing that
100 ft to 20 ft as Tracy testified it's
really important that a utility be able
to plan for their service area and
reasonably anticipated revenue and also
that communities and the state have the
authority to protect surface water
bodies and by making it so less people
would have to connect to a sewer system
both those things are jeopardized um
there are Provisions that the town could
issue wavers you know from the 100 foot
right now and so there is that ability
if a town is comfortable with having
less people connect to the sewer system
when they develop relative to the last
part of the amendment it I have to be
honest I'm not really sure what's being
accomplished here my department my
Bureau does regulate the New Hampshire
water well board and we work closely
with the subsurface Bureau who regulates
septic systems and really with the
international plumbing code when it
comes to water supply Wells it's you
know pable water is kind of what you're
looking for I'm not sure what this
provision means especially relative to
referencing the department because it
would probably be the mechanical board
or another entity that actually
maintains plumbing codes in the state so
I'm I'm I'm confused to what that
me representative bernardy has a comment
Andor a
question thank you Mr chair question so
um if I heard you right the concern
about the 20 the 100 foot being changed
to 20 foot distance um was a financial
one for the towns putting in a uh a SE a
septic line or
or or sewer line not not uh not anything
to do with the 100 foot limitation of a
uh septic system being away from a well
is that correct
correct I guess I don't I don't think
this amendment and I just got it just a
couple minutes ago references the
distance to a well anywhere in here that
would be driven by the Water Well board
regulations that we maintain and then
also the septic system
regulations um so yes it's the distance
to a sewer system that this would reduce
the number of properties that would have
to connect which is problematic both
economically and environmentally because
when a town builds a Wastewater Plant
they have a plan on who's going to
connect to it and by less people
connecting the viability of that plan is
undermined also undermines water quality
I mean all throughout the Lakes Region
we've seen the impacts of connecting the
sewers and the how the Lakes the water
quality of the Lakes became better and
so by lessening the number of entities
that would have to connect um you could
jeopardize water quality as well all the
while the town does have the authority
now to issue waivers to that 100 foot
provision but by default cut it by you
you so as I read this
amendment and compare it to the original
bill it occurs to me that I probably
should consult the speaker and the house
clerk to find out if this amendment is
germine since it modifies a completely
different part of Statute and it also
does something
that's that we know nothing about and
have heard no testimony about so that
would lead me to the conclusion that we
might need
to recess our exact session and hold a
public hearing on this amendment so what
I will do is I will get clarification
during our lunch break from the the
speaker and the clerk about whether this
amend Amendment would be Germaine or not
if it's not going to be Germaine then
we'll have to have a public hearing on
it at some future
date now we can continue with our
discussion and any questions you might
have representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned that there were
also economic concerns and you didn't
say too much about that so are you
talking about the economics of the
system development not panning out the
way it was intended or are there other
economic concerns that you wanted to
raise that's that's the primary driver
when you size a plant you're looking at
the properties it's going to serve and
you develop a plan that will fund that
plant with a certain amount of
Wastewater capacity and if if people can
opt out or do or connect sporadically it
just creates a big mess you have low
density of customers to the system so
you have all this Force sewer M and
whatnot without any utility and then
there's the environmental side of it as
well so it's revenue and lack of density
development yes of course thank you um
so you mentioned a big mess and so my
question is
um I don't really understand the point
of the bill I know it's a response to
the fact that the original Bill didn't
didn't really have legs with this
committee um so can you tell us if there
is any point from your perspective in in
this bill
so Tracy would have a better background
than I would Tracy would but from my
history at the department there's one
off conflicts throughout the state where
someone doesn't like the town doesn't
want to work Town doesn't want to pay a
sewer bill and and therefore these types
of bills come up every couple years in
my
experience additional comments
representative muns thank you Mr chair
yeah I had I can had the same reaction
that representative McGee had which was
you know what is this trying to solve
and um and thank you for your
interpretation I mean it seems to me
that you know we heard that that that
municipalities or we heard we we got
testimony from um your your your boss
commissioner Scott that um
municipalities uh can grant waivers on a
case-by casee
basis and if there are some towns that
don't have that process I mean you know
the only thing I could see is somehow
requiring that towns have to offer a
waiver process uh but this seems to be
too much of a blanket um program that
really doesn't seem to make
sense representative
Harrington thank you um I'm just trying
to couple questions on this this 20 foot
thing so to me I'm not quite sure why
this would be economic CU I'm assuming
this is looking forward only in other
words if you were going to put in a
septic system under the pre present law
I mean a source system public Source
system uh you would look out and say
this is where I'm going to run the lines
this is where how many houses are within
100 ft so therefore they're going to
have to connect and you could plan
accordingly um this would say this is
where I want to put run the lines how
many houses are more than not 100 ft but
within 20t of where I'm projecting to do
it so as far as economics go you could
you we would know the rules the rules
had change but it doesn't affect any
existing systems as far as I could tell
well there's significant upgrades that
have occurred to Wastewater plans
throughout the state that are based on
buildout plans within a 10 20 year time
frame so it it could very much upset
plans of certain communities or they
could potentially disconnect and then
there's the environmental side of it as
well followup so what you're saying then
is that uh there may be a waste waterers
facility out there that's saying okay
here's our I don't know 15-year plan
we're going to do so much for the first
5 years and then 10 years and they were
all based on that 100 foot uh connection
minimum so that by changing it to 20 ft
they could lose some of the customers is
that correct correct and then also have
stranded infrastructure that they were
going to get fill in they would never
have stretch the system out if they
weren't expecting the fill in later in
the future and and the the final part of
the on the bottom um where it talks
about person utilizing an alternative
sorage Disposal system would you
interpret this to mean that if somebody
has a alternate surage Disposal system I
guess a septic tank that if that needed
to be replaced they could replace it
regardless of whether there was a sore
now a public sore line within whatever
the minimum distance
was I read that provision just talk
about replacing an existing alternative
system with with another alternative
system as long as it follows the
regulations so I don't quite know it's
accomplishing because it's saying follow
the regulations right okay that's what
that's what I thought one last comment
Mr chairman um okay I don't know what
the international plumbing code is and I
don't know what someone putting put this
in the law saying to prohibit the use of
private Wells so I I couldn't vote for
this bill until we get someone to
explain what that what that paragraph is
trying to accomplish so I would
certainly go for opening the public
hearing again because I simply I can't
vote for something I don't know what it
is okay I want to alert the before I
call on the next person alert the
committee to the fact that 11:00 which
is 7 minutes from now we will be
suspending this work session uh
Republicans will be going into caucus in
this room and once we complete our
caucus we'll all go to lunch so this
will be the end of our work session
within the next seven minutes
okay representative
PL uh thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question um the line 27
through of this um refering RSA 4
1478 does does that apply to your
composting in
ouses or is it
just good thank you I'm sorry I just
wasn't given this ahead of time to cross
check the the various stat suits I think
stakeholders follow up uh thank you um
myself I did not have a chance to look
at that so that's why I was hoping you
would know thank you representative
licki thank you Mr chairman and this is
a generalized U statement but I think
there is an important distinction to be
made between um sit uh situations where
there is pollution there's you know
definite results I know that I have um a
trailer park and uh one or more ponds in
my district where they're heavily
thickly settled you know over you know
beyond what um the septic systems can
handle and in those cases I would see
that a realistic reason for doing a for
mandating that people connect but if
you're talking about uh other rural
areas where you know there's no
pollution issue um then would seem to me
not rural or even Suburban where there
is no real reason to compel people to
join AC septic uh sewage um dis plant
because it doesn't cause a pollution
problem and I would see a big
distinction there between which you
should mandate which you should
not okay good point further discussion
Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr chair U
suly uh after hearing discussion here I
agree this requires much more disc
discussion and and look see before I can
discussion we can discuss at exec
session after I get some clarification
from the clerk about their germanness of
this amendment we can discuss whether we
want
to recess the executive session and hold
another public hearing or whether we
want to just itl the bill
and say try again next
time so we'll decide that at exec
session any other
discussion seeing none okay let's take a
a break here call this work session to a
close and Republicans will please stay
in the room as we will hold hold a
caucus and then we will all reassemble
here at 1:00 for exec session thank you
very
much
okay ladies and Gentlemen please take
your seats and we will
recommence stn activity for this Tuesday
February 6th this afternoon we are going
to have executive sessions on six bills
the same six bills that we talked about
this morning during a full committee
work
session we have a couple of substitutes
this
afternoon we have representative Mary
hacken Phillips in for representative
crean welcome welcome thank you for
having me you bet nice to have you here
and then we have representative Lisa
Missour in for representative Summers
good afternoon and yes welcome thank you
for having me appreciate it okay so with
that we can now commence our business
for the afternoon and I will open an
exec session on House Bill
FN originally called suspending New
Hampshire's participation in emissions
reduction credit programs for a period
of two years and I recognize
representative Vice chair chair Thomas
thank you Mr chair I motion um ought to
amended chair recognizes representative
N I second the motion chair recognizes
Vice chair
Thomas uh thank you Mr chair uh we have
a Amendment 202
24-48 toh to consider for adoption and
I'd like to um move that we um adopt
that Amendment representative
ner I second the motion moved and
seconded that we
adopt Amendment 2024
0482 to House Bill 1697
Thomas uh we well thank you Mr chair we
cover that during a work session uh
today and uh we uh I think we've said
all all all that we can say this is a
this is a start we know it's not a
perfect bill but we know it's important
enough for the timber industry that we
get something going and establishing um
uh a registry and doing an investigation
as to um uh what can be done to help out
these towns I think it's important that
that's what this amendment does so we
need to adopt this
discussion
seeing none I guess uh we talked about
this adequately during our work session
so I would ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of adoption of
amendment
amended Vice chair Thomas yes
representative nder yes representative
Harrington
yes representative leeki yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Maser yes representative
Kennedy yes representative McGee yes
representative MC Williams yes
representative hacken Phelps yes
representative parall
yes representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Noel yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman yes represent
20 by a vote of 20 to nothing the
committee adopts motion U Amendment 04 4
82h and adopts the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill
FN representative Vice chair Thomas will
write the committee
report next question is should it go on
consent
calendar oops has an FN although it no
longer replies because that was to the
original bill
but all right no consent then for the
this one so this will go on the regular
calendar representative Harrington yes
the question do we voted on the
amendment do we vote on the
bill yes we voted on both at the same
time oh
okay we
did the motion was ought to pass as
0482 I I I thought we were voting on
amendments separately and then then on
the bills as
amended the clerk says you can do it the
way we did it I've had a lengthy
discussion with him about it and he says
that's acceptable he said particularly
on bills where you know that the outcome
is going to be uh non-controversial he
says if the outcome is going to be
controversial then you might want to do
it separately so that's what we'll
do all right so this bill will not go on
the consent calendar but I will close
the executive session on house bills
FN now we can move on to an executive
session on House Bill 1078 relative to
first responder organization access to
wireless tower collocation and I
Bernardi uh I move ought to pass as
amended with Amendment uh
H here recognizes representative ner I
second the motion moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of ought to
pass as
amended with Amendment
0438 on House Bill
discussion representative
bernardy thank you chairman uh so as
discussed earlier in the working session
this basically sets up one of the
divisions in the department of safety to
uh assess the gaps in radio and
Broadband Communications focusing on
needs of First
Responders uh and report back by the end
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of ought to pass as amended
by
1078 Vice chair Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative licki yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL
yes representative Maser
yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes representative hacken
philps yes representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
chairman V yes 20
Z by a vote of 20 to nothing the
committee adopts the motion about to
pass as
amended on House Bill 1078 with
Amendment
0438 H this one has no FN on it so I'm
assuming we could move forward with
putting this on the consent calendar is
that correct any
objection hearing no objections this
bill will go on the consent calendar
and representative Bernardi will write
report and with that we'll close the
1078 and if the committee will indulge
battery before we move
on
okay thank you for indulging
me I'll now open a executive session on
House Bill
1472 dfn and recognize representative
Harrington for a motion I move
inappropriate to
legislate inexpedient to legislate I'm
sorry
itl I guess we now know how you really
feel about this bill recognize
representative liwicki I second the
motion moved and seconded that we uh
judge House Bill 1472 to be inexpedient
to legislate further discussion
representative Harrington well I think
we talked this out pretty much in the
work session we could talk on it for a
few more hours but I don't think
anyone's going to change their position
so I'll just leave it at that further
discussion on House Bill
1472 representative
Ms
um again I I I I agree with
representative Harrington I don't think
we're going to change anybody's mind but
I did want to point out that uh
following the discussion we had this
morning um I did uh put in a request for
an amendment to um reduce the income
levels uh cut the income levels by
half um and to uh make sure that there
was language in the amendment that um
specifically said that leases were
included as part of the um would be that
people uh people leasing cars would be
eligible that amendment is over
56h which I have passed around my hope
would be that we would um vote against
in expedient to legislate so that that
Amendment could be considered and um we
could um have a vote on that and and the
bill is amended thank you okay further
1472 representative
McGee you and I would just just like to
ask uh ask for some leniency on this one
since this was one that was up for exec
last week when you guys didn't have a
full
compliment um and you know we would have
had an advantage then to at least get
this to the house floor with something
other than an itl so I would again Ask
folks to vote against the itl so a
different motion can be
discussion well since since we had an
fairly extensive discussion on this uh
this morning during our work session I
guess we're content at this point to
move on to a vote so I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the motion of itl on
1472 uh representative parshall you got
to raise your hand a little higher yes
I'm very sorry I'll do my best to be
taller um I would hope that we could at
least pass this bill as amended because
I think that if we are going to put a
bill before the floor we should put the
best Bill possible before the floor and
I think as amended reflects an
improvement in this bill I would
urge us to pass the bill as amended
rather than uh voting on the original
bill I would urge adopting the amendment
discussion
representative
PL uh thank you chair and now ju now
seeing the bill um I just like bring to
the chair's attention that it might go
1010 to the floor and as my friend uh
representative Pell me
mentioned this second Amendment is
better than what we have now we didn't
discuss the latest one from
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl on House Bill
FN Vice chair Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative leeki yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Maser yes representative
Kennedy yes representative McGee no
representative MC Williams no
representative Hackman philps
no Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no Representative
muns no Representative no well no
representative Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative rolds no repres
uh excuse me chairman Vose yes 10
10 as predicted by representative pl we
have a
1010 tie so the motion of itl
fails and I'm going to suggest that any
further motions would also fail and that
we should just go go to the house floor
without recommendation Mr chair may we
may we take a vote representative McGee
y may we take a vote on whether to amend
uh would this minor Amendment which has
been suggested might be an improvement
to the bill before we go to the
floor since the amendment is likely to
fail with a 1010 vote I see no time no
sense in wasting time doing
that unless the committee tells me that
they strongly feel that we need to do
this by more than 10 to
10 representative Corman thank you uh
Ian maybe I don't understand the process
fully but it seems to me that we could
vote on the amendment and then if the
amendment passes we could have a vote on
otpa if the amendment passes but the
otpa vote is 1010 then the bill would go
to the floor with otpa and the amendment
so I would I would request that we vote
on the Amendment if the amendment fails
I'm fine with dropping it but I feel
amendment further
discussion representative
Thomas just chiming in to say that I uh
strongly agree with my uh colleague
representative Corman representative
Bernardi I I would suggest a floor
forward by Mr chair Thomas uh yes Mr
chair uh I
although the amendment reduces some
dollar figure uh it doesn't um address
the point that um I think the basic
point of the entire bill so um I
wouldn't be voting for the amendment
way representative F uh thank you chair
yes I was thinking about the amendment
and representative Bernardi had
mentioned that there is still available
floor Amendment so I think that would be
the best way just continue what we
have okay further
discussion seeing none we're going to
move on
and
representative Harrington will write
the uh calendar report for the position
of itl who will write the community Comm
calendar report for the position of
ought to
okay so representative buns please have
that uh report to me before you leave
the building today I'd appreciate that
and with that we're going to close the
1472 and and move along to House Bill
1487 I will open that executive session
relative to rebates of Energy Efficiency
no relative to the health effects of 5G
technology and I recognize
representative or I should say Vice
chair Thomas thank you Mr chair I motion
itl chair recognizes representative
Kennedy I second the motion moved in
second Ed that we itl House Bill 1487
relative to the health effects of 5G
technology discussion representative
Vice chair Thomas uh as was extensively
um brief this morning during work
session um no really new information was
given uh for the Third Edition of this
bill and prior bills and uh commissions
and studies um were inconclusive as to
cause and effect and and therefore uh in
this bill in particular being all over
the place we felt that it just was not a
workable Bill thus
itl in addition to Vice chair
Thomas's uh very good reasons for iing
this bill it must be pointed out that
this bill wants to spend a fair amount
of money but appropriates zero money to
do
that making it unworkable as it's filed
representative MS
um I I will be voting um yes on the itl
motion um um but I I I do believe that
the the issues or the concerns that the
bill is attempting to address are
concerns that we should take
seriously um there was a lot of work
done by the commission that looked into
this um and um I think some of the
recommendations that the the commission
included are worth implementing but the
bill as it's written um has a lot of
issues and concern and has a lot of
issues and I have concerns with it
particularly the language that would um
Force um school districts to um move
from wireless internet um which is um
way too it's way too premature to be
doing that right now so um I hope that
um a bill that um
uh tries to move forward some of the
recommendations by the commission can be
introduced at a future date but this
bill is not the right
vehicle Vice chair Thomas thank you m uh
yes I totally agree with representative
Ms in terms of the fact that uh there
are people out there we fully
acknowledge that they are suffering from
certain ailments um there could be
correlation to being near
electromagnetic waves but extensive
commissions and Studies have yet to
prove conclusively whether there's a
cause effect there and although we uh we
would like to be able to do something
we're just not exactly sure what it is
and particularly this bill goes way too
far in in doing a solution on something
that we don't even know exactly uh what
what the real is uh you know reason is
for it yet so uh with with that in mind
that's my
rationale further
discussion
representative
parshall thank you chair I'd like to
Echo uh my colleagues uh remarks both of
them actually there is a lack of good
science out there I feel and with a lack
of good science mythology tends to come
out um but I am fully supportive of the
spirit of the bill I will be voting to
itl this particular
discuss seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of itl
1487 Vice chair Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Lei yes representative
brne yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Maser yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes representative hen
Phillips yes representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative mon Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative
rolds
yes chairman VOS yes
20 by a vote of 20 to Zer the committee
1487 I'm
guessing excuse me I'm guessing that if
we put this on consent somebody will
pull it off so
I'm still put it on consent all right
we'll put it on consent I need 10 all
right
I'm
easy so House Bill 1487 will go on the
consent
calendar and with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill 1487 who
is writing the report the report will be
written by representative Vice chair
it okay so next up let's open an exec
session on House Bill 1508 and the chair
recognizes representative
bney thank you chair uh I move interm
study on HB
1508 and I will second that motion so
it's been moved and seconded that
we adopt the motion of refer for interim
study on House Bill
158 requiring fiber optic Communication
service providers to prioritize service
restoration for Public Safety and public
health
organizations
this interim study recommendation was
actually the uh stated preference of the
Bill's sponsor and I think it's uh our
duty to honor that request by moving
this bill into interim study and
representative VI Vice chair Thomas also
feels that interim study is appropriate
I'll let him explain why uh yes thank
you uh for the reason just mentioned
plus uh I feel there is something there
when a public official involving
security and safety such as a police
chief can't get to the right person
immediately to try and solve a problem
uh when it comes to Public Safety and
Communications in my opinion whether
you're a police chief fire chief U or
other first responder that needs
immediate assistance on something that
is CR IAL there ought to be a point of
contact that they can call to handle a
particular unusual situation in this
case there didn't seem to be there
wasn't any and therefore I think inim
study might present some discussions on
how uh these people can be better served
in the future should a similar situation
come up uh such as it did and for that
reason I think inum study has some
value further discussion on the motion
representative nter
after hearing your um reasoning I'm
going to go along with the interm study
rather than
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
refer for interim study for House Bill
1508 Vice chair Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative lii yes
representative bney yes representative
Bernardi yes representative plog yes
representative Maser yes representative
Kennedy yes representative McGee yes
representative McWilliams yes
representative representative hacken hen
Phillips you had it right the first time
it's hacking like a computer hack okay
and yes thank you very
much uh representative parshall yes
representative uh Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Noel yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes chairman o yes
20 by a vote of 20 to zero the committee
adopts the motion of itl on House Bill I
mean I refer to is I'm sorry on House
Bill
1508 and this too I believe can go on
the consent calendar without
objection no objection so it goes on
consent and the
um calendar report will be written by
bne and he will attempt to have that
before he leaves here today correct good
all right so that we'll close the exec
session on
1508 and we're now down to the last bill
on our list House Bill 1576 FN relative
to allowing Property Owners to opt out
of Public Utilities and I will make a
motion of itl and recognize Vice chair
Thomas second it's been moved and
seconded that
we move that this bill judge that this
bill is worthy of it
the reason I made this motion is
because the amendment that was supplied
to us and that we discussed earlier
today in our work
session did not seem to
be an amendment that was well thought
out an amendment that was practical an
amendment that would be
effective and since it was a complete
rewrite of the original bill it seems
that while this subject may be worth
worthy of further
attention its treatment by this bill and
by the accompanying Amendment just were
not up to the task of solving the
problem that the bill tried to solve so
that's why I'm um moving itl and I'll be
interested to hear how the rest of the
committee
feels representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair um I agree with you I I I'm going
to vote itl on this however um you were
going to check with the clerk about the
amendment whether or not it was Germaine
or not did you check with the clerk and
just if if so what was the result I sent
him an email I did not go back over to
his office uh because we had already
decided before lunch that itl was the
proper motion so I can't answer that
question I didn't see a reply from him
in
email additional discussion
representative Corman thank you uh so I
agree with with your points and and to
them I would add that if another bill
comes forward about this particular
topic then it would probably go to the
appropriate committee for that topic
rather than
st& likely at least we can hope further
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chair I think the last thing I
would say on it is that I felt that the
testimony the questions that we got to
ask during the work session sealed it
for me because it sounded like it would
maybe cause more problems than it solved
so I don't think it was well focused
enough for us to be passing it into law
at this
point further discussion representative
nter and this is the first time we ever
had to discuss sewage in this committee
so I agree that it belongs in another
committee you don't want to get your
it representative partiall don't forget
to turn off your mic when you're done
speaking
any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
1576 Vice chair
Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative licky yes representative
brne yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Maser yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes representative hacken
Phillips yes representative
parshall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Noel yes representative Thomas oh gosh
sorry um yes representative Corman yes
representative rolds yes chairman Vose
yes
20 by a vote of 20 to nothing the
committee adopts the motion of itl for
House Bill
FN giving us uh five bills today
that were adopted with a vote of 20 to
nothing which I think is U quite
remarkable for our committee the other
bill was 10 10 and that will go to the
floor without recommendation but um we
did reach consensus on five bills so I
thank you for that sir and that will go
on consent as
well
that that was the original Bill
though not put on
consent all right so we won't put that
one on consent just because of the FN
but
um it won't matter anyway because the
house will adopt the itl motion I'm
pretty sure and finance will never see
it which I'm sure we be happy and who
who's writing the report I will write
the
report uh for
that as a matter of fact I already have
but I'm going to have to change it
because the report I wrote was different
okay so we're going to we're going to
close the exec session on House Bill
1576 and now I'll recognize
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um I would just like to point out that
waste management is getting into the
renewable energy uh department and so we
may be getting our hands dirty again in
the
future okay thank you for
that uh before I turn it over to Vice
chair Thomas for a couple of
announcements I want to uh indicate to
the committee that we have six bills
left to do so my plan is to do some
number of bills next Tuesday February
13th and whatever is left left over the
following Tuesday February 20th by the
close of committee business on February
20th we will have completed all our
house work for
2024 on house bills then we'll just have
to wait until we get some bills from the
senate for further work and vice chair
Thomas is going to be working on
arranging some
presentations during the month of March
since we're we're going to have some
time so if there is anybody on the
committee who would like to get a
presentation about something talk to
Vice chair Thomas and he'll see if he
can arrange that for you Mr chairman if
it's possible that we could do all six
bills next Tuesday that would be really
good and save us a trip the week after
it would be really good and I'll see if
it's possible but I'm not sure that it
will be we we'll have to wait and see
representative Marshall thank you chair
um when you say six bills to do we have
heard testimony had work sessions on
everything is that true or all we have
to do is execute is exec these S no
we'll be doing a full committee work
session followed by an exec okay thank
you thank you so
much representative Ms there there was a
bill um House Bill
1510 which I think got referred
to um
transportation is that coming back to us
no okay all right those of you who found
a copy of
1510 in your bill folder that was an
error that bill was never assigned to
our
committee okay Vice chair Thomas has a
couple of
announcements thank you Mr chair uh as
the chair mentioned uh it looks like
we're going to have the month of March
um fairly free and so that gives us
opportunity unities for presentations
and one thing is I'm going to work on I
I will try to get permission from the
speaker maybe we can arrange finally a
trip down to ISO New England if if ISO
will agree to a date a schedule and if
the speaker agrees to such a trip and of
course whether they're permitting um if
uh I I believe we we also talked about
perhaps finally after a two or threee
absence we could have Dees come here and
give us a presentation like they
normally used to do in old times and uh
we might get that on the docket so
there'll be some days uh hopefully it's
a Tuesday or depending on when
ISO can can accommodate us where uh
we'll arrange that and then you can come
in for those um presentations or field
trip once we get that arranged we'll put
out details any trips involving details
I'm going to turn over to representative
Bernardi once we get once we get uh
permission and uh break him in to this
new game here so anyway any other
suggestions just let me or uh
representative Bernardi know thank
you representative ner thank you I feel
like I need to apologize to everybody I
slipped my mind that 113 years ago today
Ronald Reagan was born and I usually
bring in jelly beans to celebrate and I
forgot well we'll forgive you this time
but don't ever let it happen
again okay anybody else have anything
they'd like to
share if not we're adjourned thank you
13th everybody who owes me a report
leave